Continue from the last section or open the level named 03 Cinematics Cam Crane.
Here you'll experiment with yet another animated camera option by using a crane.
The workflow is similar to what you did in the last section, but you'll be using a crane rig instead of a ray rig.
Make sure your level sequence is accessible in the level. You will need it to animate the rig later.
To create a rig, use the Cinematics menu like you did before.
It looks different from the ray rig obviously, but it operates just as easily.
Move it into the Cameras folder.
Note that you can control and later animate options like Pitch, and Yaw, and Arm Length as you see fit.
Much like you did before, you can easily create a new camera,
name it adequately,
and link it to the rig.
By resetting its location, it will match the head of the rig arm.
The camera is currently fixed on a single point,
but as earlier, you can pick a point of your choice by using a non-rendered actor in the scene.
You can create and rename such an actor Crane Focus,
move it to the Cameras folder,
and then set its location at a point of interest in the scene, maybe near the penthouse.
You can always adjust it later.
Once you have done that, you can use the camera's tracking options to look at the null actor.
This will ensure the camera is looking at a fixed point once you start adjusting or animating the rig's features.
To animate this rig and create a camera shot, let's add both the crane rig and its associated camera into the level sequence.
There's a chance the Solar Time Track may be muted currently.
You may want to unmute it at this time.
The same is true for the Materials Parameter Collection which controls the exterior lighting.
Let's animate the crane shot somewhere between frames 500 and 1000.
Scrub to frame 500 or thereabout.
At frame 500, you need to pin the crane in place. For that, you need to keyframe the pitch and yaw values as well as the arm length.
If you've already set these as an animation start, you're good to go.
In Sequencer, you need to create tracks for all three values.
But you can also use the Details panel as a shortcut.
Using the Details panel, you can add a keyframe for the crane pitch, the yaw and the arm length and that also creates the necessary tracks in Sequencer.
Go to the end of the animation and fiddle with these three values to result with a different camera position.
I prefer to use Sequencer to update the keyframe values.
If you need to, add another set of keyframes midway through for better interpolation.
Do not worry about the light flickering, these artifacts will not show in the final rendering.
When you're done, you can activate the Camera Shots track and add the crane shot for the last part of the sequence, at around frame 580.
Scrub or playback the animation to view the results.
We'll cover rendering starting with the next section but before you go, note that the crane may be visible in some camera shots.
To prevent that from happening, you can go to the beginning of the animation at frame 0,
enable the option Hidden in-game
and keyframe it. This adds a visibility track which now has a small keyframe set to black, which means the object will be invisible throughout.
It has indeed disappeared from the camera shots.
Save your work before you move on to the next section.